battle of gods has been widely
considered were the absolute best Dragon
Ball film since its release in 2013 but
if my rampage through the classic Dragon
Ball films has proved anything it's that
I can find fault with just about
anything nothing is perfect and while
these are considered to be on another
level I've never made an official review
of the film from start to finish so
since I struggled my way through and
reviewed every other old Dragon Ball
film I decided to ring out 2019 by
reviewing two of the most popular Dragon
Ball films to figure out for myself if
these films live up to the hype that
surrounds them today we are diving in
headfirst and dissecting Akira
Toriyama's definitive and celebrated
continuation to the Dragon Balls story
complete with ethereal music
otherworldly revelations and explosive
climactic action sequences this is the
celebrated film battle of gods
[Music]
before I sit down and watch my totally
legal coffee a battle of gods that was
obtained legally I want to make clear
that while everyone a Dragon Ball
Channel I am by no means shy about
sharing my criticisms when they surface
and if you can't take that then smash
that like button and subscribe I'm just
kidding but seriously so what are we
waiting for let's get cozy and enjoy a
good movie and hey look mythix has it
told you guys I obtained it illegally
wait bills what the hell is that five
years on and these pesky boomers are
still spelling his name wrong and you
know what the weird part is the subtitle
is supplied by Netflix call him beerus i
have so many questions and the movie
hasn't even started yet but don't blink
because the film itself begins with a
montage of reanimated key moments from
the series history giving any new
first-time viewers hopping on the 18th
movie in a 30-year old franchise the
Cliff Notes version of the story
catching is all up to modern day
Dragonball the first scene sets the
stage for bills the antagonist of the
feature both the Supreme Kai & oulq I
play this off as if it's something
they've known about all along but like
majin buu and even the Kai's themselves
beerus and we are being shoehorned for
lack of a better term into Dragonball
because they need new characters for
gohu to fight and for Vegeta to growl at
it sounds like I'm complaining here but
I'm really not Dragonball as a whole is
an ongoing series and it always has been
so to speak after its first arc and
early Dragonball and so therefore
future-proofing it becomes not
impossible when you consider the amount
of enemies the gang punches and kicks
their way through on a weekly basis I
believe the writers and Akira Toriyama
in this instance had their hands tied in
saying that they went the extra mile in
attempting to make beerus feel like a
real part of the classic Dragon Ball
universe whether it be through both
Supreme Kai and King Kai discussing him
or fears revealing his involvement in
past events like authorizing the sane
home worlds destruction these are all
retroactive changes that I would
normally hate but considering the
circumstances I think they did the best
with what they could and it made for
some interesting scenes for sure the
presence and correct application of
character makes this small grievance
easier to put up with in a big way in
the first few scenes specifically with
Goku you can truly feel Toriyama's
influence over this particular
production from the way Goku talks to
how he reacts and cracks naive jokes the
classic Dragon Ball feel is still very
much present I specifically enjoyed King
Kai driving his car
his tiny little planet through this
perfect use of character the scene
assess and the title card drops touting
a wonderful rock rendition of the
classic shala head-cha-la theme song
after this we are finally introduced to
beerus and Wiese and all of their glory
and I adore them
interestingly as weas makes his way up
to bearest chambers you can notice a few
hints towards reptilian structures this
is largely because beerus his original
design had him looking much more
reptilian than cat-like and you can
thank accurate Orianna for that cat-like
change this introduction was expanding
away where these two have been for
almost 40 years also demonstrates their
personalities wonderfully very easily
both weeks and beerus could have taken
themselves way too seriously which would
have resulted in us not taking them
seriously someone ironically instead in
their opening moments both of them
display their comedic chops showing us
that they're not OneNote characters but
fully realize personalities that are
here to stay and have something to
contribute it's through these playful
back and forth with the tube we first
hear the words Super Saiyan God
personally I have never been a fan of
transformation in this series unless it
represented something in the story I
absolutely loved the original Super
Saiyan transformation with goku and
gohan finally cutting loose going Super
Saiyan 2 was phenomenal writing however
what I think is often overlooked is that
the transformations themselves are not
memorable just because they look cool
but because the story that superseded
them was engaging and well-written
neither of those moments I mentioned
would have lasted the test of time had
all the pieces necessary for their
execution not being meticulously placed
before him in other words these moments
were earned I mentioned before that
Dragon Balls major driving scheme
throughout the franchise has been
progression through struggle this
philosophy can be observed in climactic
moments in the franchise and it's
precisely why Goku's original and Gohan
Salar transformation was as successful
in the first place both were put under
extreme stress when suddenly everything
clicked when a story is written like
battle of gods one that hinges on a
transformation like Super Saiyan God
that isn't earned and instead gift
wrapped through ceremony it loses all of
its luster going against everything that
made the series as action-packed and fun
as it was and even Goku makes note of
that in the film
that's not to say that I didn't enjoy
the design and visuals surrounding its
own vaguely I love how the form looks
but as I said that's a superficial
change not an emotional one and so I
don't really care the designs from akira
toriyama are always something i enjoy
from the reintroduction to classic
characters wearing different clothing
two new additions like beerus and we see
all of these inclusions felt very
natural and were instantly accepted by
me on my first viewing the music in the
film is minimal for the most part
understated but very effective at
setting tone when called upon there's an
abundant and noticeable absence of any
music in a lot of scenes however this
serves to enhance the movie when certain
bursts of sound design and music shine
through like bearson wheezes sudden
arrival on King Kai's world
[Applause]
[Music]
but that's not to say there aren't a
couple of catchy tracks to appreciate
also the rock we mix of cha-la
head-cha-la is one I was left humming
long after my first viewing
additionally the song hero by the band
flow is fittingly high tempo and
empowering acting as the backing
soundtrack for the major conflict of
this film the score for the movie
overall however is only serviceable and
nothing ready to write home about the
vast majority of tracks are better
defined as music snippets than actual
songs and when you compare Sumitomo work
on this film to his later work on the
burly movie in 2018 the difference in
quality and scope becomes abundantly
apparent before I move on to the action
which I'm certain 99% of you have been
waiting for me to talk about I want to
touch on the comedy and how it was used
creatively within the film the comedic
aspects have a greater presence in this
movie than perhaps any of the other
dragonballs films past or present
promoting moments of dialogue with
characters that don't play much of a
role in the film is a nice way of
reminding us what Vegeta and ultimately
Goku will be fighting for later in the
story additionally it's also a creative
and seamless mechanism to weave the
story's key plot points together the
piaff gang while many found them
annoying initially narrative ly they
served to subtly create a natural
scenario for his certain reveal to take
place the gang takes trunks as hostage
they shoot fidel in the leg and through
healing her den de discovers that she's
pregnant if this scene didn't take place
then when the gang needed another saying
to take part in the ceremony fidel
randomly out of nowhere delivering this
bombshell would have seemed extremely
convenient however thanks to the peel
off gang that was no longer the case now
on to the action there are three fights
worth talking about as they're given the
most focus within the feature goku vs
beerus on King Kai's planet Vegeta vs.
beerus and the final battle between his
super saiyan god Goku and bill's Nye the
destruction guy
the first fight in King Kai's world is
very playful and fun tons of bright
colors in addition to paying homage to
Goku cycling through the Super Saiyan
forms like he did in the Buu saga before
fighting the god of destruction the
Priya to this battle has a ton of
compelling dialogue and fight itself
does a lot in the way of animation
considering it's a glorified sparring
session I love the flick beerus delivers
to goku i adore the little details like
Goku's eyes not catching up to beerus as
he moves behind him to deliver that chop
head man when goku explodes out of super
saiyan 3 into his base form the clouds
spreading out it is so satisfying every
damn time i'm not a big fan of the
cockiness goku displays for a moment
before the fight began it feels out of
character and it seems to be very much a
trait of these modern Dragon Ball films
yet there's never anything done with it
narrative Li the Vegeta fight for me
while short delivered the emotional
height of the film and for that very
reason delivered possibly the most
popular scene of the entire movie the
considerable lengths Vegeta went to in
order to maintain peace the party was
brilliant to watch and demonstrated an
emotional growth for the character and
as soon as beerus Touch's Bulma he loses
it
demonstrated through some fantastic
action animation vegeta for the first
time in the film lands some clean shots
and beerus it's short but left the fans
wanting more which i think is the
perfect format for a vegeta fight a
similar approach was taken with the
Broly film as vegeta was tagged out for
goku to start his foot speaking of which
this fight has its ups and it's downs
for me but certainly far more ups than
downs and so I'll get the downs out of
the way first
it uses an abundance of CGI in a variety
of ways from special effect blast
backgrounds and 3d model rigs for the
most part I love the addition of 3d
backgrounds as a freeze off the
animators to focus on the centerpiece
the focal point of the attention the two
characters clashing however the
utilization of 3d animation on the
characters in this section while brief
and perhaps too ambitious was utterly
dreadful my biggest gripe with 3d
animation effects work is the knock-on
effect it has on other animators for
instance we all remember fusion reborns
amazing animation right well hideo
Shyama mora was the man responsible for
this utterly fantastic dimensional
teleport effect in fusion report however
in a recent interview he noted that
animating those sequences was a massive
pain and that if it had been undertaken
today would have been done in 3d I can't
disagree with this line of thinking more
3d should be used as a tool to enhance
what you are currently doing it should
never be used as a crutch otherwise
we're just admitting that we're not
putting as much effort into something
that we used to do while difficult the
end result in Fusion reborn last stood
the test of time and as a result is
marvel to this day the team behind
Fusion reborn clearly had the time to
get everything they wanted to finished
on time and all the action sequences in
the movie were completed perfectly the
use of 3d in this scenario would not
have been necessary and unfortunately
the same can be said for battle of gods
the sequence with which they used the 3d
character models didn't need to be 3d to
achieve what they did in the film that
and the character models looked like
garbage the rest of the fight I am happy
to say looks spectacular it's pretty
difficult to discern which anime er did
watt in the film mostly due to tateo she
and Mamoru
and drawing over all the animation in
the film to present it as a consistent
style but the obvious stand out and
highlight of this action sequence has to
be now Toshi Shiva's amazing cut as
Super Saiyan Goku first from the earth
and soars through the heavens I don't
need to tell you about it because let's
face it you've all probably seen it
already it's incredible I also love the
added sense of suspense the movie
delivers - with the Super Saiyan God
time limit all the time during the fight
we are left speculating and wondering
when the form will run out of juice and
what it does it's fantastic and
cathartic to see Goku still hang in
there even when his speed isn't working
anymore watching him solve this issue
with techniques like instant
transmission and creative flanking is
incredibly engaging and fun to watch
unfold I do give up so when all is said
and done do I think this movie holds up
yes absolutely
this movie for a long time was
considered to be the best Dragon Ball
film and while I think Dragon Ball super
burly takes that distinction I don't
think it could be understated how
important and refreshing this film truly
was released during a time when Dragon
Ball wasn't mentioned outside of a
random OVA or video game Dragon Ball Z
battle of gods resurrected a beloved
franchise from the depths of irrelevance
into the mainstream
once again paving the way for yet even
more feature-length motion pictures and
a 131 episode long hugely successful
television series watched by millions
around the world the film has its flaws
some of which can be seen as irritating
depending on your mood but the
high-octane action provided by master
animators the classically nostalgic
Akira Toriyama dialogue and the
magnificently ambitious story that blew
the universe wide open for the rest of
the series to explore is more than worth
the price of admission and cost of
purchase if you haven't seen this
wonderfully camp thrilling film and you
are a Dragon Ball fan
I couldn't reckon
more here's hoping I can say the same
for another modern dragonball film that
I'll be reviewing next week but until
then I've been totally not mark thank
you so much for watching
you